I saw you guys on the red carpet for
this and you told me how much I was
going to enjoy it at least I think you
did and I did it was so it was just just
so incredibly fulfilling like I thought
you guys did such a great job your
performances as well as this movie so
congratulations and I'm sure you're
hearing a lot of that I mean that very
sincerely the dynamic between you two in
the film also was I mean as as actors
that must have been a fun dynamic to
play I mean there was a lot going on
there between your character he's a
nightmare it was good to just sort of be
able to lean into that that's exactly
you just kind of have to go with it yeah
yeah
describe that system quickly for me like
no because because it's it was three
years in teaching it you know both of us
but she's we have we have a similar way
of working so and it was great I don't
know about you but sometimes I find
myself apologizing to people yeah I'm so
sorry if that was a bit weird and
intense yeah no we didn't have any of
that
no yeah because you managed exactly you
go yes exactly
I like that well so let me just point
out the obvious here Game of Thrones
Avengers and now Star Wars I mean you
guys like sign a deal with the devil I
mean this is incredible
yeah really lucky yeah who's training
more people should I have to jump right
in because we have limited time here
we're gonna play a little that's okay I
just I know it's a little bit rude but
kind of keep it moving a little speed
round with you guys it's called draws
Thrones and Infinity stones Hey
nice nice what was beautiful here we go
most hardcore fanbase I have to say
downs but it's because I haven't
experienced the Star Wars fans fully
yeah yeah I haven't it hasn't come out
yet I have to say the for me the
Avengers have been that the fans are
just crazy
[Music]
yeah that's a great point I think it's
likely right yeah no question it's like
choosing between kids I feel like at
this point stricter NDA's and worst
consequences for breaking the
non-disclosure it's Ryan's Thrones crazy
crazy this season crazy crazy definitely
have their own detectives when there is
a leak
they absolutely find where the leak came
from and it's quickly and quietly dealt
with yeah pretty pretty unpleasant
experience for the person lake do you
know this firsthand no I might um he
messed up once I have I keep my mouth
shut
it's amazingly do I love no you're still
walking most elaborate costumes
I mean Game of Thrones people let's just
like I'm sorry about any but I have to
go through it even though they're
superheroes over there let's I mean I'm
working dragons do you know what I mean
yeah that's how you say this literally
Jack Jack sure but he's not sure no I
mean my you know a fan of Game of
Thrones I'm a huge fan of inverse of the
sine of the costumes in the MCU are
believable and and mind begin with pair
of lips and a pair of Spanx a harder
dialogue to remember you speak like to
pretend languages they're pretend
languages they're not even there
pretentious can you just make it out now
I tried it ups I literally tried to make
it up and in and I ended up instead of
saying Dothraki I just started going B
buh buh buh turbo
but ever do any harm I'm a scat man
that's quitter maybe or later like you
know 80-yard anyone so you know like cut
stop it's not funny
we're running late on we want to make
the day yeah very last question I'm
wrapping up timewise this is just for
you
Jon Snow or Han Solo oh wow
I think I'm think somewhere near
there'll be some kind of I'm on Star
Wars I must say this I don't understand
I don't get it
he wants to be in stores why did you go
go to choose good point
ooh get frightened yeah I'll take both
Thank You Buster plan
[Music]